A vaccine is a substance that
teaches your body to recognize and fight off
things like viruses and bacteria. Vaccines work
by looking as much like the virus or bacteria as
possible without causing the harmful effects of
the disease. Vaccines can be made from a weakened
form of the virus itself; from unique pieces of
the virus; from a chemical that the virus creates;
or even from substances that scientists
make that are similar to parts of the
virus. After you receive a vaccine, your
immune system will recognize and attack
the virus or bacteria if you are exposed to
it later. This means that you will either not
become ill at all, or you will have a milder
response to the infection. Vaccines use your
own body to fight off infection. Vaccines are
very effective — and they’re the best protection
against many serious diseases. Most people who get
vaccinated will be protected against the disease.